Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr it's time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday,
November 26th,
2017 what's going on?
How,
why?
Yeah.
[inaudible] what's up?
What's going on?
How would you thanksgiving I would you thanksgiving week.
Oh,
it's over.
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that a great weekend?
[inaudible] it's the best.
It's if you don't fucking,
if you don't have to go anywhere,
first of all,
you know,
if you get,
you get a wife and you got a kid,
you don't have to go anywhere.
People just come into your place.
It's the best,
you know,
all your stuff is there in the end.
People help clean up.
We,
I had,
I literally,
I had the perfect thanksgiving.
It was perfect.
Did I want to thank everyone involved?
Oh,
I can't yell at my daughter's asleep.
Fuck,
I'm taping this at night.
Sunday night.
Um,
the potato sweet potato pie killed.
I think I gave out some misinformation.
I just bought the wrong kind of sweet potato.
I bought a,
uh,
it was the white one,
which I'm hurt.
I use for other desserts,
but not for the Pi.
But people do actually use sweet potatoes for sweet potato pie.
You can add,
also actually use yams.
That's what I used.
Yams,
brown sugar,
cinnamon,
some Nutmeg,
a little bit of ginger.
Um,
some vanilla,
whatever,
in a whole bunch of sugar stirred the whole thing together.
And I tell you,
I was sweating it.
Okay.
Fucking white guy making a sweet potato pie.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I'm living dangerously here.
I thought I was going to get booed like at the Apollo and uh,
maybe people were just being nice,
but I think,
uh,
I think everybody liked it.
Um,
so I was psyched.
And then my stuffing always kills my stuffing.
Always kills.
You know why?
Because it starts off with me melting as an entire stick of butter in a pan.
That's where,
and I go from there.
I don't care what you're making,
you can't lose.
If you start by melting a stick of butter in a Pan,
you know,
um,
he's fucking lunatics nowadays.
They will take that,
oh,
can I pour that entire thing into my coffee?
I don't know what's going on.
All right.
I have a lot of stuff to promote.
I apologize for the AC,
but it's as hot as shit in here.
I don't know if he can hear that.
Run over my loudest voice here.
A bunch of stuff.
The sixth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit will be Tuesday,
February 20th,
2018 at 7:00 PM.
People always go,
hey man,
why is it always on Tuesday?
Because I got a bunch of comics working for free that night.
I can't have it work for free.
And I'm money night.
Money as in Cha Ching.
Not as not Monday night and on a Monday night,
a money night.
Um,
all right,
it's going to be 7:00 PM at the city center where we've always had it.
One 31 west,
55th street between sixth and Seventh Avenue in New York,
New York,
one double oh one nine.
Here's the lineup.
Brendan Burns,
p Cory,
Allie Jo to Raul,
Joey Roses,
Sam j,
Robert Blobby,
Kelly there,
Jessica Curson,
um,
Sifa sounds and rich Vos,
uh,
with more special guests to be announced.
Um,
ticket prices are 75 bucks every seat and all the money other than what we have
to pay to rent the fucking place.
Um,
goes to a,
goes to his mom.
All right.
And his,
uh,
what would have been his wife,
but he never got around to Marriner.
I don't know how to say it anyways.
Uh,
anyways,
there's three ways to buy the tickets when you go.
I'm gonna have all these,
all these links,
by the way,
are up on my website,
all that stuff.
Okay.
Um,
and you can,
there's a number you can call if you're sitting in your cubicle right now.
Two,
one,
two,
five,
eight,
one,
two,
uh,
at the theater and at the box office.
You can go right to one 31 west 55th street.
All right?
It's gonna be,
it's gonna be Tuesday,
February 20th,
2018 at 7:00 PM.
And thank you to everybody who's been coming for all of these years.
Um,
because of you guys coming out,
we've been able to keep Patrice,
his name and his comedy alive.
And everybody that,
you know,
that was in his life has that he was helping to support and everything has
remained living comfortably and been taken care of.
So I'm,
it's the,
one of the things I'm most proud of as far as all the things that,
um,
you know,
I've done in this business and I've watched my friends do the fact that we all
get together and make sure that his mom and his family are right around right is
,
uh,
is a great thing.
So anyways,
onto the podcast,
well,
if I'm going to promote some stuff,
I might as well promote a few other things as a speaking of comedians and I got
to get her on this benefit one of these years.
A good friend of mine for way back in the day became a filmmaker and is now back
is back then when stand up on my ad to Giorgio.
Um,
absolutely fucking hilarious.
And I was talking to you the night at the comedy store.
I didn't realize.
I told her,
uh,
you know,
my,
I really fucked.
I really fucked up my side big time by playing drums.
I think I already told you guys that how I was down there and I was just telling
her that,
you know how I messed it up and then I re screwed it up by playing drum.
She's like,
I didn't eat,
play drums.
I used to play drums.
I started talking to her mother,
used to be this famous jazz singer and she played at the cotton club and all
this stuff,
that real jazz gigs and shit sit in with all these legends.
Started talking,
all this drum stuff.
And she's a great comedian.
Anyway,
she's going to be a December six.
She's going to be at levity live in Oxnard,
California,
which is just outside of La.
It's a Wednesday night.
Um,
she's just fucking awesome.
So definitely check it out.
I'll have the link up there for that.
And lastly,
Judah Freelander has a new special on Netflix called America is the greatest
country in the United States.
And me and Nia was sitting in bed watching it really low on the volume because,
you know,
I lovely daughter's sleeping in the other room and just cracking up.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's brilliant.
I haven't seen him in so long because he's a New York guy and I'm a big La phony
here.
And uh,
I sent him a text.
I told them how he,
that guy is fucking brilliant man.
Uh,
definitely check it out.
It's so cool the way he shot it.
It looks like almost lead us in black and white and probably did with a couple
of I iPhones that's just shot over the course of,
I don't know how many months of him screwing around doing bits fucking with the
crowd,
you know.
And he just would just would cut out and just say,
the seller,
this date,
that date all shot at the cellar.
It's uh,
it's really,
it's really different.
It's awesome.
Judah Freelander America is the greatest country in the United States.
All right,
that's it.
Let's get into the end of the podcast here.
All right,
let's dig in to the God damn podcast.
I'm in a good way.
I did not do shit
this weekend.
I didn't do shit other than this morning.
I woke up and I got all my tax shit.
You know,
I do it at the end of every month.
I just get all my stupid receipts.
I organize them so I don't have a fucking avalanche,
you know,
April 14th to go through and throw it my accountant and make his life miserable.
I don't do that.
End of every month like a little old lady.
You know,
I try to balance the books.
I just do all of that.
And then all I have to deal with is whatever bullshit I did in the last 30 days,
rather than having to deal with 365 days.
It's the smartest fucking thing I've ever done.
Because I remember,
I remember back when I used to live with Bobby Kelly,
right?
We would sit in and,
and you know,
we would do like a zillion spots a week.
You know,
on the weekend you'd have like six,
seven,
eight spots a night,
you know,
and I was working in uptown and downtown,
so I'd have all these cab receipts and have all of these receipts from College
Gigs,
club gigs,
bus tickets,
train tickets,
all of this shit shoved in like four different cvs bags by the end of the year.
And,
you know,
we had to do our own taxes back then or whatever,
and we would just be sitting there with this shitty fucking coffee table with a
giant plastic bags of receipts that God,
Dude,
why did we do this?
Why did we fuck it?
Why didn't we just along the way at least just have an envelope that said taxi
receipts that I would try it every year and on a good year I'd make it to march,
you know,
but I never made it for the whole year.
Most years I wouldn't even make it into February and I've just be like,
Eh,
fuck it.
Um,
but this year,
finally,
years later,
25 years in my career,
finally,
you know,
I finally been doing it.
And,
uh,
I kinda know where shit is,
like major shit,
life insurance and stuff like that.
I kind of know where it is.
Like I know it's in one of two different places.
I don't know which folder,
but um,
it's really made my life a lot easier.
Um,
or who's getting to my wife if make her life easier.
If I ever die.
It's like,
it's either in that box there in that box and it's sort of organized.
MMM.
So anyways,
yeah,
I did not do shit this weekend.
Still didn't drink.
I made it through.
I did not drink.
So I'm up to 102 days.
By the time you listened to some in triple digits over there,
I'm like,
fucking will channel it a bit.
So I got him by two fucking days.
Two points.
MMM.
Yeah.
It wasn't that,
it wasn't that bad.
No one was really drinking.
So the temptation wasn't really there.
MMM.
And once the night was over and my daughter was awesome and she didn't cry
nothing.
She's just like,
she's so cool,
man.
He's so chill.
She's so,
you know,
when people,
people actually say that when she gets upset,
she looks like me.
That's when she looks like me.
You know what I mean?
And as much as that hurts me to hear that,
I know it's true.
So anyways,
um,
I ended up,
uh,
I,
you know,
when I'm home I usually am the one that puts her to bed.
I actually really enjoyed doing it and I haven't down to a whole system.
And,
uh,
the worst part is after they fall asleep in your arms and you got to set them
down in the crib and then they cry for a little bit and just walking away
knowing they're fine now when they just crying,
they were okay.
MMM.
That's the hard part.
But,
uh,
I actually enjoy her falling asleep,
you know,
laying on my arm so much that I usually let it go for like an extra 20 minutes
cause I figured some day,
you know,
she's going to be like,
Oh my God,
Dad,
God,
you're so embarrassing.
I'm,
I'm really trying to take all of this shit in.
So,
um,
anyways,
I put her to bed
and uh,
was watching her on the little video and then I went out on my back porch and I
smoked arguably the best cigar of the year.
It was just perfect.
You know,
it was thanksgiving.
It was an event.
So there was no guilt of like,
look at me smoking a cigar.
What am I,
some bomb at a track.
I said I smoked it.
It was fucking delicious,
delicious.
So it couldn't have gone any better.
And just when I thought my weekend couldn't get all any better,
I decided to watch every college fucking football game I could get my eyeballs
on.
And I did.
And it did.
I see some bright ones who please tell me,
please tell me you son of a bitch that you fucking sat down and you watch the
war on I four interstate for that runs between the two underrated cities of
Tampa in Orlando,
Florida.
They don't get any respect.
You know,
you gotta be on the East Coast and south of Lake Okeechobee to get any respect
in Florida.
Even then,
they still laugh at you and if,
if just,
if you're living in Fort Lauderdale,
right?
You're up north on Daytona beach.
They all know you're doing meth,
right?
You gotta be down in Miami.
I got a buddy of mine for show.
He's going to be on my shows out there in Florida.
I'm doing show Hollywood,
Florida and in Orlando go into a magic game in between knocking off another team
and,
uh,
he's a Miami guy.
So I was trashing the most,
making fun of Miami.
I was like,
dude,
every guy in Miami is either a drug dealer or a promoter
or both.
I know that isn't true,
but I just like trash in places that I enjoy going to.
Who doesn't like Miami?
Um,
anyways,
so interstate four runs between Tampa and,
uh,
and uh,
Orlando and I watched that game.
That game was fucking,
it was like watching a god,
this was like a video game.
I can't,
I can't even remember what the fucking score was.
It was like 42 35 and I got to tell you something with some of the fastest,
most athletic to the fastest,
most athletic teams I've seen in a long time.
And I know that,
I don't know if they're not division one,
I don't know what their deal is.
I don't know where they are.
But I know I've seen a lot of like good players come out of south Florida,
central Florida.
Um,
so I don't know what happened.
Maybe they fucked up in high school,
you know,
punched a teacher.
I don't know what happened,
but these guys look like they could take on.
Anybody granted that at the same,
I don't fucking know.
It looked great.
Okay.
Everybody was flying around the field.
So,
you know,
there was very few white people out there.
You know what I'm saying here?
Um,
so,
uh,
I'm watching this game.
It's 42 35 and um,
central Florida is trying to be the first team ever in that conference or
whatever to ever to ever go windless and within two years go undefeated.
So they have a chance to do what they go 40 to like 35 or some shit and there's
like a minute and a half left.
Right?
What are you going to do?
You're going to go into the prevent,
you're going to give up the whole,
the first fucking 80 yards and then you're going to go into,
then you're going to start finally playing defense.
Right.
You know,
I hate the fucking prevent defense.
Well Guess,
guess what Central Florida does?
Evidently they didn't go into the prevent
cause inexplicably.
Somehow this fucking guy got behind their defense with a minute and a half left
for like a 70 80 yard touched out,
which by the way,
it was like a 20 yard pass and then he just ran 50 yards.
So I immediately tweet and all caps.
How the fuck do you let that happen?
As I'm finishing the tweet and hitting send,
it's now tied 42 42 south Florida kicks the fucking ball off,
a stunned stadium of central Florida fans are watching going,
can we at least get down to field goal position that we just fucking blow our
whole season?
Fucking do it in central Florida.
Catches the ball that kickoff and ran the fucking thing back.
So then I had to tweet again.
How the fuck do you let that happen?
So now it's like 49,
42.
I'm sure he got the school wrong with.
So they both in the forties
and then I'm sitting there going,
well
those two plays are so fucked up.
They did easily central Florida could run this fucking ball back of south
Florida,
should say,
um,
they didn't,
and the game ended,
but Jesus Christ one an entertaining game.
And then the next day I watched a Michigan,
Ohio state,
and then I watched the iron bowl,
um,
and watched Auburn beat Alabama and uh,
watching Michigan
Verse Ohio State.
I've come to the conclusion that I fucking hate quarterbacks who run.
I hate a running quarterback.
I just can't,
I can't fucking stand,
you know,
I don't think it should be legal for a quarterback to run.
All right.
Or if you run,
then you get treated like a running back.
This whole fucking thing that you could wait till everybody,
everybody covers,
they called the right defense.
Nobody's open and then you can just take off running when nobody's fucking
looking.
That's all well and good,
but you should get stuck.
But it's all like he gave himself up.
He threw himself on the ground.
Leave them alone.
Fuck you.
If you're going to take off running,
you should get stuck.
Either that or keep you fucking fucking running around as behind the goddamn
line.
It's fucking driving me crazy.
I'm a Michigan Fan,
so I'm watching that shit.
And Michigan's fucking defense was lights out and that fucking cunt
can't run an eight yards,
nine yards.
Guy couldn't complete a pass.
He couldn't feel pressure,
but he could fucking run.
And then when he ran there to be like,
Ooh,
he's a quarterback.
If I was coaching for the other team,
I'd be like,
listen,
hit the fucking guy.
Take the take the penalty.
I don't give a shit.
I'm not saying deliberately energy him,
but fucking hit him.
I don't care.
Now it drives me up.
It drives me up.
The congratulations to our house.
I don't hate Ohio state or whatever.
I'm just more of a Michigan Fan.
Um,
and Michigan's just in a weird year.
I don't know what their deal is.
I mean,
they,
they don't have their quarterback.
I hate trash and college players because they're still kids or whatever.
But he could have had a better game and use a little amped up in the beginning.
And I dunno what happened on that last play.
I think a miscommunication.
Maybe the guy ran broke off the pattern or whatever cause it will,
you fucking threw it to the guy.
But um,
Jim Harbaugh,
oh,
in three.
Oh,
in three against Ohio state.
You're telling me his wife had a good fucking weekend.
So he comes home with this fucking woody Hayes glasses all steamed up.
Um,
yeah,
but Jesus Christ at Defense Michigan's defense was great.
Um,
and how about the kid that came in after,
uh,
Ohio state quarterback went down.
He played great and he could throw the ball,
he could throw the ball and run.
Um,
so maybe they get a future with him.
I have no idea.
And then I,
you know,
my,
I got a buddy Jay law head is a big Ohio state guy,
so he's always arguing the case as to why Ohio,
Iowa state should be in the fucking playoffs every,
he did it to me last shift fucking talking to me.
He tried to explain to me how Ohio state should be in,
in the,
the,
the 14 play off.
And it's like,
dude,
they lost to Penn state.
Penn State won the big 10 championship.
Penn state doesn't make it in,
but Ohio state does.
He goes,
yeah,
I'll tell you why.
Strength of schedule early,
fuck,
it does all the fucking math.
And then what happens?
They play Clemson and they get the old right there,
Fred right.
31 to nothing.
You know,
somebody else should have been in there.
So I love Jay.
He was doing that to me again the other day via text,
and I'm just laughing,
thinking like,
dude,
he's always talking about our Alabama stinks and there's nobody fucking in the
sec.
It's like the big 10 sucks to pick 10 still sucks.
It's not that good.
Penn state was overrated.
They were overrated.
They lost to Ohio state and it was a huge fucking went.
And then the very next week,
what happened?
I owe state beats,
Penn state the next fucking week.
Penn state loses to Michigan State and Ohio state gets fucking raped rate by
fucking Iowa.
So I dunno.
He's always talking about how weak the SEC is.
It's like you get the fuck out of here.
You look at the big tent,
Jesus Christ.
How many teams you got laying down every week?
Rutgers,
Indiana,
Purdue,
Northwestern.
Fucking Minnesota.
I hate to say Nebraska,
but that they're no good.
That's six fucking teams right then Michigan state is always half assed.
Oh Man,
I'm going to get some fucking mail this week
in Michigan.
Isn't that good?
There's still trying to put it together.
So who the fuck are you playing out there?
I don't get it.
You know,
look at fucking Auburn,
Auburn beat Georgia when Georgia was number one and now they beat Alabama in
Alabama was number one.
So Alabama is number one.
They take a loss in the last game of the season.
So now at they out,
the whole fucking thing is just,
it's just a,
a symptom of the game.
You can't have the march madness because everybody would be getting concussions
in ruining million dollar fucking career.
So this is the best system we got.
So I guess it creates arguing,
but I gotta tell you,
um,
what a week.
Just the college football was fucking amazing.
Then I watched a little bit and I never watched PAC 12.
I watched it live that Washington,
Washington state,
Jesus Christ,
a bunch of players on those teams too.
Um,
and for some reason my wife just let me do it.
You know,
it was funny,
you know,
we actually,
we went out shopping after the Michigan fucking Ohio state game and I was so
fucking pissed.
I was so fucking pissed cause I just felt like Michigan's data better defense,
they should've won.
And they just kept doing that little cunty fucking eight yards scamper for a
first down to keep the fucking drive alive was driving me crazy.
Um,
and then uh,
I dunno and then we just went out and I just say like,
you know,
I don't know why I get that into games,
but you know,
my,
my half could sense it and I just said,
yeah,
listen,
I just fucking,
you know,
I just watched the game.
I did not like the outcome.
Right.
This is because Jesus Christ.
All right,
so then we'll walking around,
okay,
we're with all these people like you know,
Christmas shopping and shit and you know,
there was this group of fucking Asian people,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
They will,
for whatever reason,
we're walking down the sidewalk like 17 people across and we were behind them
and they will walking like half a mile an hour.
I don't know if they just got done eating Thanksgiving dinner.
I don't know what it was,
but I was having what this comic,
I used to know John Bush used to call it walk rage instead of road rage.
He used to do this great bit about having walked rage in New York City and I was
just sitting there like,
how the fuck do you not [inaudible] I get it.
There's a whole family.
They are with their grandparents,
you know,
an agent.
People respect their elders.
They're not like Americans.
When we would have thrown those old people in the home and we would have picked
up the pace when we walked down the street.
So I was trying to respect their culture,
but at the end of the day,
I'm selfish.
So I was just like,
oh,
what the fuck's?
We finally get bye
and my daughter didn't want to be in the fucking
strollers.
So I got her out and I'm carrying in my ribs of fucking talking to me and one of
my shoulders is fucked up my mind.
I'm a mess,
right?
I'm like,
you know,
I'm like a fucking journeyman quarterback right now.
I'm like,
Steve Grogan at the end of his career,
I should have been walking around with like that fucking neck brace.
So I'm already grumpy.
And then this lady's kid is having a fucking temper tantrum and was stopped at
the,
at the red light waiting to walk across the street and this kid is hitting this
fucking note that is making my ears,
which are junk from playing drums,
vibrate in this painful way that's making my teeth hurt.
So Nia goes,
hey,
we can cross up here and right as I do that,
the fucking woman with the screaming kid heard it too and started following me
and is a saint aviation.
She was a beam up my fucking left eardrum,
which means just right alongside of it.
And I just,
I was walking away and I couldn't see.
She was right,
but I couldn't understand why it wasn't getting quieter.
And then she came,
I turned around,
I saw that she was following this up there and I just,
I,
I snapped,
I snapped.
Okay.
I was under my breath.
Caught Jesus fucking Christ can get just fucking get that fucking kid the fuck
away from me.
I was gone near stop.
Just let him go past Jesus fucking,
it was,
it was completely irrational.
I was 100% wrong,
but,
uh,
it was just all those things building up.
And like I said,
I already walk around it as six,
so it's very easy for me to get back up to a 10.
So,
uh,
you stop talking to me.
And uh,
then I was like,
ah,
here we go.
You know?
And then I was a baby about it.
I'm like,
Oh really?
Do they,
they showed up for football game.
I'm driving over here.
We just bought this.
I did this.
I took the fucking garbage joke
just cause I drop a bunch of f bombs in public about some other woman's crying
kid,
you know,
I did the dishes.
That's not a push.
It's not a wash.
You know,
I thought like,
I thought that all balanced it out.
So,
you know,
I put up a good fight on the ride home and then I find just a mess,
like,
yeah,
right.
You're right.
I'm just arguing with,
cause I know you're writing.
I'm embarrassed.
I shouldn't have done that.
Yeah.
MMM.
What do you,
what are you going to do?
I mean,
they wrote a song about me a long time ago.
Huh?
I'm not a perfect person.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know why I did that.
You know,
something I would go to fucking anger management,
but I just don't feel like telling my stories all over again.
I've already gone to therapy.
I just don't,
you know,
I'm going to retell these fucking things,
going to reboot it like fucking full house on a Netflix.
Okay.
Oh,
she's gotta have it.
They just keep rebooting shit.
Doing the same shit over again among,
but I'm going to do that.
Tell these fucking stories all over.
I'm sick of my stories.
That was part of my argument too.
I was just like,
you know,
Nia,
this is,
you know,
something,
this is who I am.
This is what I do.
Okay.
I,
uh,
I'm really good at being a comedian.
I make a great living.
We have a great life,
but every once in awhile I'm going to drop a bunch of f bombs because a baby's
crying.
Okay.
That's who I,
and you have some,
I usually babies crying usually makes me laugh because I'm usually on a plane
when they start crying and they were expressing exactly what I'm feeling and
it's just like,
it's like a great comedy.
It's just like,
dude,
I hear Ya.
That's exactly what the fuck I'm feeling.
MMM.
I don't know.
It just all built Ohio state beat Michigan.
Then there was the,
uh,
hands across America,
Asian family that I couldn't get around and,
and there was like 20,000 other fucking things going on too.
It was just like,
it was a shit show and I fucking a Christmas shop and,
but by the way,
dude,
I've,
I've crushed it this year.
All my nieces and nephews all have presence.
They're all wrapped and a mailing them out to respective families this week.
Okay.
Hey Sanna,
go fuck yourself.
I beat you by four weeks.
Granted you have to deliver it to the whole world,
but you know,
whatever,
whatever.
San Is the number one seat.
I'm like a 60 to seed.
I got into the
dance.
Sell
no more.
Third.
Yeah.
16 seat in a bracket.
That's right.
Right.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Let's do a please,
please buy tickets to the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit.
Uh,
so we can do this again.
We have some surprise guests.
Hopefully I'm breaching out to some big names.
Nudge,
nudge,
wink,
wink.
All right.
[inaudible] everybody.
Um,
all right.
Oh Shit.
Here.
I got to guess I got to sing a song.
[inaudible]
losing my shit over a crying baby.
But due to,
to me on these,
beyond the,
he's,
uh,
why didn't you join the navy?
Because I'm scared of the fucking ocean,
but I would have fought a shark not to listen to that fucking babies.
Sorry,
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm all over the map.
Right?
Every,
every year.
Millions of people receive.
That was it?
Yeah.
I just,
I fucking snapped.
I don't always know when d is not going to talk to me anymore because not only
did she not talk to him anymore,
she gets this look on her face cause I started looking at the side of her face
and I'm just like,
oh,
that's that.
Look,
I know that look,
uh,
I know what she's doing.
She's rewinding 20 years of her life going,
how the fuck did I ended up with this guy?
Um,
all right.
Mandy's,
every year,
millions of people received the least light gift of all time underwear.
Yeah,
but we still give it up to our family and our loved ones who just don't want it.
But many will do by the way.
What does that fucking underwear that they,
they,
that they sell?
Oh Shit.
Look who's here.
Oh,
come on,
on the podcast I was talking about how when I got mad at the baby.
Oh Jesus.
The look just came right back.
Yeah.
Huh?
You're still shaking your head over there.
Yeah,
she didn't hear me.
It doesn't matter.
I heard you.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
Uh,
I heard you and they didn't like it.
Oh,
you want it.
Can you sing the me undies jingle about what an asshole I am.
Butoh do too.
Mandy's [inaudible].
He's a fucking
in news.
Sure.
Yes.
Mia Knees.
What have you got
Lou?
Who's,
what are you doing?
You doing this dude,
dude,
it's me.
Ids me on days.
No more sweaty.
We really
mean it.
Yeah,
you got that part out.
Whatever you,
you're right.
Okay.
Every year,
millions of what's,
what do you give you see?
Does it gross you out?
That guy's underwear commercial with,
they're like,
no pinch,
no stink,
no something or other and it shows some fat redneck dude.
It's like,
I know.
I don't want to know that yet.
Tate smells like deer urine cause you just got back from the forest or whatever
those fucking people do.
I mean,
it's for,
it's for a practical purpose.
It's not supposed to be sexy.
It's not supposed to be inviting or whatever.
It seems to be like for fat white guys.
It's definitely for white guys.
Fat White Guys.
I mean fee they draw on the guy's fat.
He's not even Husky.
Yeah,
he's a little thick.
He's fat.
Yeah.
I guess he's fat.
Do you want that crawling on top of you?
Uh,
I don't mind the Husky fellow.
Really?
All right.
We must not like,
oh,
I'm looking because I'm crushing it lately.
I am wafer thin told you not to get too skinny.
You should still have a little,
you know,
not something to hold onto because that's a weird,
yeah,
that is weird.
But like don't get so like you get,
you just get,
so you really do get men or exec like you get so like upset.
Oh I don't need it.
This is the fucking weight I was when I came into this business and people
weren't like,
oh my God,
your man or Rhexis that you,
what it is is you get used to what I look like after eating,
drinking a thousand fucking classes of booze and pizza.
That's all beer and pizza.
Then if I actually get to the weight that I'm supposed to be,
you're like,
oh my God,
you look sick.
My heart is psyched right now.
It never said you look sick.
You said,
I look like I have aids in,
don't you bill?
That's not even funny.
I would never say that.
Don't tell people I said that on the puck.
You said it and you made a sign and you held it up in the kitchen.
Oh,
I did not.
See he's exaggerating.
Don't know.
What did you say?
No,
wait.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
You said you want to,
do you want some Rolaids?
Yeah,
not,
not those are those assets.
You didn't,
I see what you thought.
You said you had aids.
Alright.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Mondays.
Mondays,
no more blood disease.
All right.
But maybe it's not the,
that underwear is the problem is the kind of underwear.
Let me tell you about me undies.
It's he only underwear.
That's makes for an amazing gift.
Soft,
flexible waistband.
Alright,
Mandy's.
I'd love you guys.
But who's kidding who this is a stocking stuffer.
Don't lead with this.
Okay,
this,
this gift is not batting cleanup to Susan.
Nice little soft landing.
I got you the fucking thing you wanted and here you go.
His is very soft though.
Hey Nia,
all I'm going to get you for Christmas as me.
Undies.
How you feel about that.
I would love some meander,
you know that's all you're getting.
No,
I want more than that.
Why?
Because I don't want to just underwear.
Thank you.
And when I give you the underwear,
where should I put it up your age.
I did a lot of that over the net and it's a stocking stuffer.
Sorry I'm too close to the Mike here.
It's three out of copy.
It's all for dollar shave club.
Okay.
Why don't you get a microphone.
All right.
I just so you won't be off Mike so people can hear you and I can also get
through the,
by the way,
people can hear me just fine.
Like people tweet me that,
that they can hear me while you're sitting there.
Beulah,
Google.
Good here you,
you're used to screaming into a microphone,
which is hilarious to me because the microphone is meant to amplify your voice.
It's meant to carry it,
but you like like,
yeah.
Yeah,
I'm criticizing.
Yeah.
I'm threatening you.
Yeah,
I'm threatening.
You're good.
Sit Down here then
I'm trying to find the,
no,
I'll look it up.
All right.
I'm just giving you shit.
Well,
you got to get another microphone.
The microphone is in the other room.
Okay.
I'm not doing that.
All right.
I'm not doing that yet.
Did you know me undies is three times softer than cotton.
It's very soft.
Very soft,
isn't it?
Is that horse muzzle?
Soft [inaudible]
that's my favorite touch.
Like the,
yeah.
I don't know what you call it.
What do you call it when you have a favorite thing that you like to touch?
If you said this on our first date,
that wouldn't have been a second day.
Oh,
that's my,
that's my favorite touch.
What do you call it on?
There's the thing you like to touch.
I'm a little hoarse.
Muddles like my favorite things other than our baby's beautiful face.
[inaudible] made underwear.
The perfect gift that everyone is going to love you for.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle this year.
They'd have the in the copy this year.
Give the gift of me undies this holiday season to get your exclusive 20% off
that softer side do and socks you'll ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird.
That's me undies.com/burp.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
Dawlish I told Ya Joe Barton,
he told me about that homeless guy he ran into in Milwaukee.
No,
he came up to the homeless guy.
This is his joke to make you laugh.
To give him money.
He came up two weeks [inaudible] he goes,
hey,
did you hear Bob Barker died?
And Joe Goes,
what?
He goes,
yeah,
he got hit by a new
car.
So stupid Joe laughed.
Design is a buck.
Um,
all right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Dollar Shave club ships.
Amazing razors for a few bucks.
A what?
You might not eat dog.
Bob Barker.
Not Ted,
right?
I don't know.
I hope not.
And I really hope he wasn't hit by a car.
Well he definitely wasn't he a parked car.
TMZ would've been over there telling you,
read the fucking Vin number.
Dollar Shave club ships.
Amazing raises for a few bucks.
What you might not know is that dollar shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the bathroom.
Man.
Body Wash,
shampoo,
Hair Gel,
pube,
clippers,
lip balm,
everything.
They don't have a coupon clippers.
Now you don't have to step foot good.
You could shave your pubes with their razor as,
I mean no one's telling you not to.
No one's telling you to either.
Certainly not here on the podcast.
Okay?
I know that head moves for to go around around your chin.
I don't know if you want to fuck with the junk.
Okay.
Started the year off,
right?
Shave your shaft and your balls.
You heard it here.
Don't do that.
We do not condone that.
Joke's made on the podcast or not to be taken seriously.
Do not reflect the views of the yes.
Yeah,
the illiterate reader here.
All right.
Now you don't have to step foot in a store to get high quality shave and
grooming products.
Dollar Shave Club delivers them right to your door just like their razors.
Everything is super high quality and you will,
one will have you looking and feeling amazing from premium ingredients to
sophisticated sense.
Dollar Shave Club is changing the game.
If you're sick of the nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try out dollar shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower shave started set to new members for only $5 to start a set features the
exclusive executive razor and the three trial size versions of their most
popular products that help you stay so fresh.
It's so clean.
And your first box you receive the shave body wash in one wipe Charlie's but
wipes.
Um,
there is no way to wipe your ass in one white putted.
Just isn't okay.
There isn't have to wipe your whole ass or just wiping the whole yeah,
just one wipe and you,
you're good with that.
You're confident to pull up your underwear and your drawers and just walk
around.
Not Thinking you gotta be a little bit and go over it a couple of yeah,
you should.
One wipe Charlies.
How but fucking four wipe Eddie's
it a little swirl there.
Um,
you will,
I'm doing shit jokes here.
You also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handles in a focus set of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offers exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar
shave club.com/bar and if you want it to get a great gift,
give him dollar Shave Club.
Uh,
they got super simple gift memberships at at e gift.
Any gift cards.
Fuck Dollar Shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There's no better time to try the club and mercifully wait,
can I just say something?
Can I get my water?
Just about like the whole shaving thing,
especially for dollar shave club.
Are these
razors,
are they like Gillette style?
I mean,
why wouldn't they be real re razors and why did you just name their competition
in the middle of it?
First of all,
this Coca Cola.
Does it taste like Pepsi?
No.
Is it uh,
you know,
uh,
no,
it's a toy in here.
It doesn't even do the job.
It's just they're just doing this for fun,
for fun.
Since I'm saying,
is it like,
what do you call it,
the blades that you put them in the thing and then you open the,
you open the,
not a safety razor.
That's what I mean.
It's not,
oh no,
it's like the one I shaved my head with.
Okay,
Gotcha.
Okay.
I just wanted to say,
because for the safety razor,
you know these people have been advertising for a long time.
Please don't ruin this for me.
I've lost so much advertising on this.
Can we just,
all right.
All right.
Never mind.
Don't poke.
This is the golden goose here.
Them and stamps.com these kids,
they have ride or die.
They don't give a fuck what I say.
[inaudible].
I Love Dollar Shave Club.
I love stamps.com I loved,
I loved them all you love,
you love old zip.
All right.
stamps.com with the holiday almost.
Here it is.
It just was Thursday,
right?
Thanksgiving.
That's all.
Today
it's time to go San.
Is that the mall?
Who has time to go to the post office?
It'll be busy with people sending holiday cards and gifts.
So do what we do.
Use stamps.com instead.
I'm so stupid,
I never thought to do this.
I want to do with my posters.
Why don't I send out all those gifts?
Using stamps.com brings all the services of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class a mail using your own computer and printer.
Then the mailman picks it up.
stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide
that the best class of mail,
every t o help you decide the best class of mail every time.
Print postage any day,
anytime stamps.com is always open.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters.
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you,
and right now,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter Berbee you are
are all right with that.
Let's read some of the,
uh,
some of the letters from my listen.
Is He,
if I'm listening his bag,
he stole eight.
Ooh.
Well last year
I'm reading all of these.
I read all of them.
This is got like another 20 minutes.
Hey,
what's she rushed?
Okay.
Relax.
Sit down.
Take it easy.
Okay.
All right.
Okay baby.
Okay.
All right.
Progressive Rock.
Oh,
by the way,
fuck you Australia.
Whoa.
Yes.
Fuck that whole country for not telling me about the wonderful Australian group.
See what I did there.
Oh,
I got everybody down there.
I went to have,
all right.
What's this fucking fucking shrimp on the Barbie.
How do they talk down there?
I know it is.
It's also a country.
Okay.
And it's an island.
They don't know what they want to be.
Um,
how the fuck do you have all these weeks I've been asking you for a great
fucking new band.
My drum teacher just told me about this band.
Carnival.
A sound awake.
I listen to that album.
Jesus fucking Christ.
What a band there are.
May I?
I cannot recommend that's,
that's the one.
I don't know any of their other albums.
That's the one I got sound awake.
They're fucking drummer.
I got to get the guy's name right now.
What is his name?
I Bet I've been so listening to that album.
I didn't even look up the drummer's name.
It's fucking amazing.
Um,
where is it?
I don't know.
What are you doing?
And I'm looking at all the windows you have open on your why.
Why are women so fucking nosy?
That is so creepy.
I'm just curious.
What was I looking up cunt with a k maybe.
Alright.
Carnival.
A drummer.
That's how it's spelled.
Did they pronounce the Carnival or kind of Steve Judge.
Jesus Christ.
That guy's a beast.
Incredible.
Top to bottom.
Everybody in that band,
Singer,
Guitar Player,
Bass Player at the whole fucking thing.
That drummer.
Unbelievable.
Please download that.
Listen to it.
Tell me how much you love it.
Australia where you got to,
you got any more bands like that or what do you hold now for every week I'm
fucking sitting here like a little,
a little kid,
you know,
on Christmas.
But no presence.
Just asking them.
They don't tell me anything.
I go down like toy,
go all the way out to Perth and what thanks to I get.
Oh Australia.
That's not cool.
Yeah.
I that that fucking album came out in 2010.
Why they treated me like that.
Neyo all right.
Anyways,
out anyways,
shout out to little creatures.
Beer.
Can we read the ones that I feel like I'm going to be able to jump in on first
and then I can leave and you can do what?
Don't care.
Can we
the last two progressive rock.
Oh,
I know you don't give a fuck about that.
I'll read that one.
All right.
Emily Linden tweets.
You don't want to do this one?
No,
I don't know.
All right.
What or who is Emily?
Linda.
I didn't know who he tells.
She was either.
She is somebody on the Twitter sphere.
She,
she's uh,
she's got,
um,
social media.
She tweeted some a shit about,
I don't know,
some shit.
I don't know.
Hey there,
Billy fair trail.
Um,
I imagine you've been sent this article many times over the last week I had,
here's an excerpt from an article about what the writer for Teen Vogue tweeted.
A,
here's an unpopular opinion.
I'm not actually all that concerned about innocent men losing their jobs over
false sexual assault slash harassment allegations.
The benefit of all of us getting to finally tell the truth.
Plus the impact on victims far capital's far outweighs the loss of any one man's
reputation.
He said adding,
if some innocent men's reputation have to take a hit in the process of undoing
the patriarchy.
That is the price I am absolutely willing to pay.
It's hilarious.
You're not paying a price in that,
that the innocent guy is,
um,
the most cognitive cause I say the words stupid critique of Linden came from CNN
anchored Jake tapper.
The lead host tweeted,
well,
this is CNN.
There's bad as Fox News.
I'm guessing you didn't get a good grade for your seventh grade book report on
to kill a mockingbird.
Uh,
referencing the classic novel that features the trial of a black man falsely
accused of rape in the 1930s,
Alabama.
Um,
you said if some innocent men's reputation,
I have to take a hit in the process and doing the patriarchy that is a price.
Same.
Absolutely willing to pay.
That's immoral.
Tapper wrote and it's not a price you would be paying by the way.
It would be an innocent,
innocent men doing that.
Um,
all right.
He said,
my wife is black,
is back to the guy running.
My wife is black and she has a cousin who served six months in jail for being
falsely accused of rape.
He lost his academic scholarship,
academic,
not sports scholarship and has been having trouble getting his life back on
track since having his conviction overturned from being physically and
emotionally abused in jail.
She said,
uh,
that is she ever
alright.
She said that if she ever saw this woman in public sheet and I quote,
slap the shit out of that irresponsible cont bill.
I've never heard of used the seaward or even threatening violence against
anyone.
It's like that line.
Now you just go into a completely different direction.
That line from Batman,
the dark night,
you either die a hero or live long enough to see yourself become the villain.
All right?
You're all over the place.
I don't know what's going on here.
Um,
what do I think that,
I think that's the tweets have somebody young.
Uh,
and,
and also it's kind of seems that it's a little WWE wrestling,
grandstanding,
knowing there's no way you write that,
not knowing,
you know,
it's like watching down there,
the,
the notorious guy there and the MMA guy,
the crazy shit.
He says,
he knows what he's doing.
Yeah.
And then everybody's like,
[inaudible] too cocky.
I want to watch your moves.
And then that he wins and he
gets your money.
I think that that's a,
I think that's all this is,
uh,
white feminism.
So that's pretty much,
yeah.
I mean,
that's pretty much,
this is why people don't like being labeled a feminist because of stuff like
that.
No.
Elaborate.
Nah,
that's all I'm gonna say about it.
Okay.
I feel like nobody white and knows who you're talking about.
But everybody black right now does.
Oh my God,
was that shade?
Am I woke?
Um,
yeah,
I mean that's just one of those,
uh,
I dunno.
I don't know.
I mean,
what do you do you know what?
That's how she feels.
What am I supposed,
am I supposed to actually like,
like respond to that?
Like that's like some sort of rational human being.
What do you mean what this person foaming at the mouth.
I don't know.
They remind me of myself
when you think of this complete.
Yeah.
And yet can I make this city more easier for you?
I love how you,
you will only wanted to fucking respond to the ones that were easy and they want
to give you a chance to respond to you.
Like you like bill Belichick laying off.
She's a,
yeah,
it's white phone is,
I know.
Cause you know,
but I,
but I can elaborate.
I can get into these next to elaborate.
I don't want to,
I don't want to him.
Why?
I don't know.
Maybe I am being a worse,
but I just,
uh,
yeah,
I,
it's,
that's,
I don't know,
there's really no other way for me explain it than to say that that's,
it's just you.
It's a level of,
okay.
Not,
not,
they're not naive.
They're not
like maybe just in a bubble or something.
Just like,
so sheltered,
sheltered.
So it's like all they can focus on is like the one thing,
you know what I mean?
And they just can't quite grasp.
Yeah.
Well that's a joke I do on my act.
You know,
when,
like when I listened to feminists,
like it's hard for me to listen to white women in the United States of America
complaining.
[inaudible] like going,
do you know,
you know what it's like to be me a slightly less awesome than what my life is.
Like
if you look at the big picture,
um,
I'm sure that seems to be a giant gap between me and you,
but if you look at everybody else's situation,
we were at what kind of sitting on the same stone here.
So why don't you buy a run around the lady?
All right.
I'm sorry.
Am I a rebound chump?
Is this good idea?
Is this in your wheel house?
Yeah,
I think so.
Keep going.
You'd be a great president.
This is what president is due now.
They'd like,
they basically,
I don't like the way that guy asks questions.
Let's bring this person in.
You don't have time for everything,
so you gotta you gotta weed through?
No,
I,
I do have to.
I have time for all of these.
You don't have time.
I mean,
yeah.
I'm not talking about you talking about me.
Can we read this one?
This one looks good.
Okay.
All right.
Am I a rebound chump?
Probably.
Dear Billy forehead.
You're saying all this funny shit off the Mike.
I'm telling you,
but they say and they can hear you.
I said probably repeat it again.
All right.
The time.
Yeah,
the time he's gone.
All right.
Huge Fan of your comedy and podcast.
Did you hear that?
Nia?
Huge Fan of my comedy.
Huge,
huge,
greatest,
greatest comedian ever going to do.
Stand up on a golf course with my own name attached to it.
Donald Trump would think of your podcast.
I mean,
I don't care what he thinks about anything,
but I wonder what he would think about your podcast
as far as what?
I don't know.
Like do you think he would be into it or not?
Even though you trash them,
you trash everybody.
I think he's busy running the country.
I don't think he's listening to fucking early nod by the way that he tweets.
He's clearly not that fucking busy.
He's not that busy.
Who has time to tweet the petty shit that he does?
He's got that.
What's great about Twitter doing all this?
The actual stuff.
He's just sitting there like,
you know the,
uh,
what do you call it?
The spot?
Like,
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck.
He's just,
and he's working.
He's got me all,
he's working Obama.
Bill Clinton work today.
Yeah.
That's a guy who worked at,
yeah.
Oh,
I just get all flustered.
I can't even speak straight.
Anyway.
Come on.
Am I a rebound chump?
Is Trump really that bad,
dear Billy?
Forehead side?
Just like get Nia going.
I dislike it.
It's really,
I mean,
I don't know.
You've got gotta give the guy and shit.
Why is the worst time in here?
Cause it was hot as fuck in here.
Oh,
you usually the one who runs hot.
I know,
I know.
No,
Am I a rebound chump Nicole,
can I tell him to shut the fucking thing off?
Jesus Christ.
This is why it takes forever.
You the second you bring a woman in the fucking thing.
Like if you're going to leave that house,
everything has to be perfect.
Shut the fuck.
Oh my feet are together.
Rub them together like issue will.
You're always are.
I need a Blakey.
Are you ready?
Okay.
Yes.
Huge Fan of your comedy in the podcast.
Hearing you shoot the shit every week obviously makes me laugh,
but also gives me insight and other things.
Anyways,
it's hard to find out.
All right.
I get too many comments.
Thank you.
I met this girl Butoh little dude.
He's probably the best or that check while blah blah,
blah,
blah.
I've ever been with and our personalities so far looks just as good.
We are both in college and neighboring states,
but we hang out a couple times a week on average.
Things have been going great for the past two months.
We have traveled around her state and she has shown me places I have never seen.
I did not expect anything to bloom like it has and was originally content with
just being friends who fuck.
However,
after getting to know her better,
she definitely seems like someone I could stick around with for awhile and maybe
even date.
Um,
well what are you guys now?
Sightseeing?
He just said they're hanging out.
Oh,
just hanging out.
Okay.
Sorry.
Well,
if I have to read and also listen to what I'm saying,
like I can't do that.
The only thing is
that's called reading comprehension.
Bebe.
Yeah,
I'm not good at it.
Um,
the only thing she has and the only thing she got done.
Yeah,
the only thing she has an ex who I suspect she's still hoping we'll come back.
All right.
Incident one on our second date quote,
she rented a movie on an Amazon on our x's account and got a texted him asking,
Huh?
What that was about.
Oh,
you fucking sector about an Amazon movie.
Wow.
Why is she,
what was she?
What is she doing?
All right.
That's some bullshit right there.
You know,
good.
And God damn.
Well you can't order on your ex's account and like they're going,
they're still paying for that.
Ooh.
See the little mink.
See this one.
She seemed delighted that he was forced to communicate with her and she wired
him money and said,
sorry.
Incident number two.
So he's obviously broken up with her.
Fucking dramatic.
Uh,
you ready?
Okay.
Incident number two.
She originally stated that they broke up back in February,
but one night she let it slip that they had actually broken up in August.
Just a couple months ago.
I acted like I didn't notice.
Good.
That's probably good.
After banging one night,
she starts joking about having a baby and what features it would have.
I have brown hair as the she and she ran over the,
says the baby could be blonde,
the color of her exes hair.
She then went on to say your ex's name was one of her favorite names for a boy.
Oh my Jesus Christ.
Dude,
this is always good.
My God,
this is getting ridiculous to the point,
I'm starting to not believe it.
Thankfully she waited until I finished all my dick and balls would have deflated
immediately during all this baby slash x talk incident number four,
Jesus Christ,
buddy exhibit 1995.
Um,
she still uses her ex's,
Amazon prime account to watch movies,
but on two occasions she began snooping through his order history right in front
of me,
either unaware of how off putting that is are simply not giving a shit
disrespectful to myself and the x in my opinion.
Uh,
another confusing twist is that she gets pissed off and sad if I referred to her
as my friend.
We're not in an official relationship,
so this would suggest that she is at least kind of interested.
But with all this stuff going on about Rx,
I think she might just like the attention I provide and thinks she may be
stringing me along.
She is also randomly accused me of using her for attention and having other hose
,
uh,
neither
of which are true.
Yeah.
You don't sound like a,
yeah,
that has a lot of hoes.
Sorry for this long email.
It's hard to put all this bullshit into words,
which you are great at.
If the,
yeah,
he's in the emotional side of this.
Maybe me just reading what you just wrote out loud will be enough.
If the lovely Nia is nearby,
I would love to hear her take as well.
Thanks.
Uh,
and go for a jog once in awhile.
Yeah.
All right.
What do you got it?
Yeah.
This girl is fucking crazy and she's not over her acts and she is using you to
get jealous.
And if you don't mind banging her because she's hot and all that and letting it
go,
then fine.
But if you're starting to catch feelings,
I would bail.
Wow.
You said that nice and quick.
I agree with all of that.
I concur.
That's exactly it.
If you could somehow not get emotionally tied to her and just keep banging her
disrespectful as fuck,
she is incredibly disrespectful.
She does not care about you at all.
The things that she is saying and doing in front of you is so ridiculous.
Like how are you going to lie in bed with someone and be like,
you know when I have a baby,
like I end up this,
you know Caleb,
because this is also like,
so Michael Shit,
like Caleb,
I just feel like it'd be the perfect name for a boy and he's just sitting there
like,
are you serious?
Like your ex boyfriend?
Oh yeah.
You know what?
This could be great rude.
He should be en route.
He should just,
I dunno,
I think you should just say something just like,
listen,
you've,
I have,
but this is one of these people that [inaudible] you don't even say anything to
him because it's not going to,
they're not going to sit there and be like,
Oh wow,
I guess you're right.
I really shouldn't have done that.
It's just person.
It's not going to give a fuck.
So whatever,
man,
you get to paying a hot chicken.
She's not over the other guy.
So who gives a fuck?
Thank God you didn't marry or they'll do and thank God that other guy broke up
with her cause she seems,
I don't know.
Granted it's all you.
You're
talk has the nerve to be mad at him.
When he called,
when he introduces her as a friend,
she has the fucking nerve to get mad after all that craziness that she's putting
him through.
[inaudible] get out of here.
Classic hot chick.
Crazy hot chick behavior though.
This is classic,
crazy data to show that I've told,
I think I told the two weeks ago that hot chick I'd met at the gym and she kept,
you know,
giving me a number and she'd wanted to go out and I kept trying to get her up
but she wouldn't go out with me.
And then finally she picks a date.
Yeah come over,
we can hang on Saturday.
And she goes,
oh I'm moving.
Can you want me to help her move?
And I just burst out laughing because I'm not fucking doing that.
Huh.
And she had some other chump who came over there too.
There's going to be the two of us standing there like maybe if I pick up
something heavy you can fuck males is like,
she's all yours buddy.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean I can't knock the hustle,
but that's incredibly rude.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
That's why that right there,
that statement.
I can't knock the hustle,
but that's incredibly rude.
Funny.
That's why.
Oh,
you're just being funny.
Honestly,
that's,
that's why I,
I I get all that,
that that male feminism horseshit where they just sitting there drinking the
fucking Koolaid.
Like women just,
you know,
there
aren't as many,
just as many fucking absolute sociopath psychos that have vaginas out there is,
it's not drinking the Koolaid.
They're just saying what they think women want to hear and then they turned out
to be fucking assholes.
So Jesus name you just really get cut to the chase.
So cut to the chase here.
I'm trying to do an hour here.
You just fucking bang,
Bang,
boom.
Done.
All right.
Girlfriend wants plastic surgery.
How do you feel about that title?
Nia,
is this an easy enough class for you?
Yes.
I'm excited to hear this.
Hello.
Bill.
Big Fan of your work could use some lady advice here.
All right.
Is this a lady?
I don't know.
Oh,
some lady advice.
Sorry.
My girlfriend has been dropping hints for months,
months now about getting plastic surgery.
Knows in Boob job bump on [inaudible] bome bu a while while she looks perfect in
my eyes.
She said she hates her knee.
Her June knows in her tiny tits.
She has,
she has big pea size cup.
Uh,
she has a pea sized cup.
Sorry.
That's me.
Whatever the fuck it's called.
Brow or whatever the fuck it's called.
Which like he,
he,
he not which w h I.
C.
H.
O.
This is witch on a broom,
which is all I need.
I tried to ignore it for as long as I could.
Now she says she wants it for Christmas to fake press one nose job.
Sorry.
Oh,
that was a good joke.
And you shush me.
Sorry.
Baby sleeping,
sorry.
And a bag of fucking tampons on the third day of Christmas,
my true love gave to me three fucking removed.
No moles to boob jobs.
One bleach asshole
and a bag of botox in a pear tree.
Come on,
let's do the plastic surgery on the fourth day of Christmas.
My true love gave to me for corrected hammertoes three remove no moles to fake
tits and a bleached asshole and an in a pear tree.
I can't fucking do it.
Sorry.
Go on.
Go on five inches off my pussy lips.
They hung down too far.
One bleached as whole to and some botox and a pear tree.
Nia,
can you get me hair plugs for Christmas?
We're going to go all the way to 12th on the 12th Day of Christmas.
My true love gave to me was what would you get?
12 things of 12 stretch marks removed.
You go 11 to bleached tooth.
Tooth is bleached to bleed.
Seven eyebrow hairs plucked.
I don't know what to say.
Nick,
can you get me here?
Plugs for Christmas.
But here's the thing,
I just want them right down the center of my head.
I want to get,
I want to grow a Mohawk.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
while she looks perfect,
she says,
okay.
She Bob up button.
Now she's saying she wants it for Christmas.
Jewish though.
Sorry.
Or She's antisemitic?
No.
You know what a lot of Jews celebrate Christmas.
What do you mean antsy?
Some.
Oh yeah,
maybe she goes again and I got an Undergrad,
I went to him.
Did you notice,
you know these,
you say like that she celebrates Christmas,
which I actually have two Jewish friends to celebrate Walmart titch to hang out
in the side of my overalls,
you know,
so I know it's so stupid.
Act like only only southern white people are racist.
Oh Wow.
All right.
Um,
now she's saying she wants for Christmas.
I told her she's perfect the way she is.
I love you just the way you are.
Um,
but she has low self esteem,
which he,
which dude is w?
H I c h not which w?
T c.
H.
Wd is w.
I.
T.
No,
it's w h.
I.
C h or w.
T.
Z private pilots.
Oh,
all right.
Which he is probably why she uses,
why she's with my fat,
ugly as to begin with Jesus Christ.
Both of you guys know you're both like,
you know,
you have each other.
Just Rub your ugly body.
Oh,
neat.
Wow.
That close to the holidays.
Am I a bad influence on you?
You're never mean like that.
That's fucking hilarious.
People know that I'm nice.
They just,
you know,
I have,
I have my people like me who like me,
but I have,
you know,
I have my moments where I can be a little rude for no reason.
Hey,
well this,
he's describing it this way.
I couldn't resist myself.
Yeah.
Can sometimes two negatives make a positive?
They have a great looking kid.
Um,
all right.
We got into it the other night about it and now she's saying she's not happy in
her own skin.
Oh God.
She wants to be a dude and if I truly loved her,
then I should expect it.
I should accept it and get it for her as a Christmas present.
Said some,
I was being a dick about dude on a manipulative fuck this chick.
This chick wants to get her.
No,
she's trying to trade up.
She's sicky you fat,
ugly ass.
She wants you to buy some fucking save some of your cake money and spend it on a
fucking tits or to knows.
Right.
And I'll fuck that shit.
Fuck that shit.
I said I haven't felt this way about a girl in a long time.
I love her the way she is and I don't
want to see a fuck up or looks or a body.
I don't know what to do here at Billy.
Boy.
Any advice would be appreciated from you and the lovely Nia.
Yeah.
Fuck this.
I,
I think you get out.
Um,
you're saying he should break up with her,
get out used to break up with her.
I should help her with herself.
Esteems fuck that.
What you're just going to give up on somebody you love because they have a low
self esteem and they're like freaking out about it and no,
you know something.
I was,
I,
that was my advice until she said,
you should buy me that for Christmas.
No fucking expensive.
That is,
yeah,
that's very expensive.
No,
no dude,
no nos.
Is she watching reality TV?
She's going to try and get it on real housewives of fucking de Moines,
Iowa,
wherever the fuck you guys.
No,
you should really like if she's really trying to do this,
it's her body and it's her choice.
She should pay for it.
If she really,
really wants to do it,
she should save up her her pennies or whatever it is.
Save up like $100 a week or whatever the fuck it is.
Cut Out all this other stuff,
bullshit that she's doing,
going out with friends,
going out with you,
whatever the fuck and she should save up for it and just be like,
I don't feel comfortable and get with like paying for you to alter your body.
That's not something that I,
you know,
believe in.
That's not that maybe I have the money for.
It's like this is your body,
this is your choice and I support you either way B and no,
no,
no.
And I support you either way,
but I don't feel comfortable paying for it.
It was a sound of a dump truck backing up in the alley that you should just drop
her in.
Yeah,
no,
I love you,
but this is not,
I'm not doing this.
I would get out.
I feel comfortable.
I gotta be honest with you because those are boundaries right there.
And that's not,
that's not something you feel comfortable and easy thing to do.
You are perfectly well within your right to say no to that.
And if she has a problem with it,
then yeah,
I guess she can bounce and she's going to pass those
slow self esteem,
body issues.
Ondor Ondor your fucking kids.
It's going to be a nightmare.
She needs to go to therapy.
Oh,
I don't know what the fuck she needs to do,
but if I was you fuck that.
Fuck that.
Fuck that you can you sit me and you need to pay for it.
Fuck you.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
I would come over there.
I would dress up like Santa Claus when I broke up.
Whoa.
Get the fuck out of my life.
I'm spending all my money on me.
And to do you need,
if you think you're fat and ugly,
you can do something about the fat and you can get a fucking personality.
So why don't you get all the money she wants you to spend on tits?
Wow.
What are you fucking get a trainer.
Get a fucking training for yourself.
Do to fucking move on from this train wreck.
Give me a Jesus Christ and almost ruined my fucking thanksgiving.
Yeah,
no,
I'm just kidding.
Anyways,
don't listen to me.
I'm not trying to tell you to fucking break up with it,
but that,
that,
that's a major like,
like,
what the fuck did you just say to me moment?
You know,
don't text during the Goddamn podcast.
Someone's let them know where we are.
What are you having somebody over Bobo,
boop,
boop.
All right.
It's my,
it's my ex.
I'm using his Netflix account right the front of you.
So fucking deal with it.
Yeah.
With you.
It'd be,
you know what I think is a great name.
Lamont,
um,
Prague.
I'm trying to pick a stereotypical black name from way back in the day.
There was nobody named Lamont,
by the way,
except that guy on a San Franciscan
boo boo.
All right.
Progressive Rock.
Hey.
Oh,
Billy Baru.
Furred.
Uh,
glad to hear you looking into more progressive rock,
like every genre of music,
99% is unimaginably derivative.
Trash in 1% is really unique and well done.
Yeah.
Fay,
I like your perspective.
Your percentage might be a little harsh.
I'd like to think 10% at least as good.
Even the good stuff can be off putting at first and just take some time to
digest.
Uh,
like good scotch.
It might be harsh to most people at first,
but if you put the time and you find a lot of interesting shit going on,
uh,
early generous genesis is some of my favorite checkout.
The tracks,
the musical box watch.
Did she wake up
okay.
A watcher of the skies and dancing with the moonlit night.
The compositions are complex and beautiful and Phil Collins Collins was really a
perfect drama.
Yeah,
he's one of my favorite drummers of all time.
Uh,
the band also had some amazing tracks,
like close to the edge,
a heart of the sunrise and gates of delirium.
Bill Bruford was one of their first was on one of their first few albums and was
a beast.
All right.
You're already mentioned King Crimson.
They had some truly great song,
but always had a few improvised stinkers on each album.
Check out 21st century schizo oid man LARCs tongues in aspect part two and
starless Bruford his drumming on two of those tracks.
Finally,
he got to get into magma who was one of the,
who has one of the best drummers who have walked the earth a hundred even heard
of this guy,
Christian Fandor.
It's really his band.
He composed all of the music and their sound is totally unique.
They sing in an alien language so you don't get distracted by stupid lyrics.
Well,
what about their alien language?
That sounds like something that sounds like a sketch.
Will Ferrell would be at almost 70 years old.
Vander plays incredibly.
They are so good live that I've flown to La and London just to see them play in
the past couple of years.
I'll have to check this out.
Look up live videos of them playing the last seven minutes and zombies.
Your drum teacher will vouch for them.
They ease easy.
I'm also psyched to hear you mentioned Meshuggah.
Uh,
Oh yeah,
they've aren't believable.
Uh,
there were another
one that takes a lot of time to get a feel for,
but once you figure out that almost all of their songs are in a strange kind of
four,
they become one of the grooviest bands you've ever heard and there's no coming
back.
Enjoy your foray into the weirdness of progressive music.
You speckled asshole.
That's a good one.
Speckled asshole.
That's it.
And they won.
So Nia,
how was your thanksgiving?
It was delicious.
I don't mean the meal.
I mean,
how was the weekend?
Oh,
that's great.
Thank you.
There you go guys.
That's what I come to him to
rating positivity.
What you just said.
That's what I come home too.
I was like,
great.
Thank you.
And you said,
yeah,
that's what I come on zoo as if I was to some like negative Nelly.
No,
you just sounded like I was asking for your autograph as you rush through an
airport.
Great.
Thank you.
Do you want me to say,
I just want you to throw a roll of paper towels at me.
That's what you should've done.
Stop it.
Get away from me,
uh,
get away from me.
He doesn't get it.
Stop it.
Get off of me.
I will clean myself.
I'm always picking at me.
You're a mother now.
Go downstairs and go fucking pick your daughter there.
Isn't she beautiful?
She's over here.
She's knocked out.
You can hear her breathing cause she's got a little stuffy know.
I know we had the best day though.
Little snuggle.
What did you guys do?
Uh,
we watched the end of the Patriots game.
You know,
I watched the whole Patriots game and uh,
you know,
everybody's,
that's one of the reasons why I don't get overly excited about a nine.
And to record when you play in the Miami Dolphins,
which is already uh,
just a,
a franchise that has been transitioning,
trying to get to another level for fucking decades,
it feels,
feels like,
and you know,
Jay Cutler isn't playing and it's just one of those games.
We got like three,
four sacs,
which are gonna Pat our numbers.
So then we go into the plastic will be all day.
They got a decent pass rush and blah,
blah,
blah.
This,
like teams like that,
we'll pad your fucking stats.
I've got to say that backup quarterback was actually pretty good.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I just,
and I love and Dhamaka Sue,
I don't feel he's a dirty player.
I just think that that guy plays in the wrong era.
He is,
he is a fucking Dick.
Butkus violent world of Sam huff type of football player.
He's just playing in the millennial age.
I love that guy.
Um,
anyways,
so we watched that.
Then I've started to watch some of the rams saints game,
which was a great game.
And then,
you know,
she had a runny nose and stuff,
so I was constantly,
uh,
having to deal with that.
And I don't know that I read some books.
She liked that baby phase.
It's book.
Yeah.
She loves that book.
I read that book too,
like five times.
Really?
Yeah.
She loves it.
She likes it cause you act it out.
That's like,
you know,
yeah.
But she gets the faces too that they're making,
you know,
like,
like happy face,
you know.
And then the last one I'll be like,
I go,
I,
you know,
I go laughing.
I'm like,
kicky kicky and she'd look at me going,
hey,
he laughs too.
It's fucking awesome.
That's a little like
she has like,
she still has those,
the big belly laughs.
Like when you really get her,
you know,
like you'd go,
Oh,
I got her yesterday,
you know?
But then she does a little Kiki Kiki also,
which is like funny.
No,
but I got the belly blast yesterday when you was still mad at me.
Did you hear how hard I was making her laugh?
Yes,
I did actually.
Yeah.
Uh,
where were you going to talk about that?
About your,
about what you're like completely,
you know,
being mad at the wrong person because you were upset about a game and like that
something,
wasn't that what it was was I was carrying Lola,
my ribs were killing me and then her in the Stroller,
I told her because she didn't want to be in the stroller.
I know,
but if she like has a moment where she's like,
Eh,
she'll be fine.
You keep it moving and she's fine.
She's not one of those,
cause she's not at that stage yet where she just screaming for 10 minutes
straight.
That's not who she is.
And plus she has to learn that you can't carry her all the time.
Yeah.
But no,
but she also wrote all the way over there in the car and then we walked up the
street,
we come back down the street.
She was like,
I'm over it,
you know,
in the this strapped in like astronauts.
I eventually,
I was like,
get this fucking thing off me.
I understand.
It's like,
yeah,
I wouldn't like to,
I mean I'd like to be wheeled around,
but after while,
but by the time we got stuck in the ride at six flags.
Yeah.
That's what they feel like.
You think so?
Yeah.
Like fuck,
I gotta get out of here.
Yeah,
probably.
I would think so anyways.
Like having a full on parent conversation right now on the podcast and nobody
cares about this.
Alright,
sorry.
Anyways,
that's the podcast.
A Happy Thanksgiving post Thanksgiving weekend to you what?
What did you say about being mad at that little boy when we were going down the
street?
What did I say?
I don't know.
When I came in you were saying you were just talking about it.
Did you talk about Utah?
I was gonna.
I was saying,
I said,
do I do this?
No,
I do that and you're just going to be a good dad.
I realized I was being a baby because I was embarrassed with my behavior there.
Is that enough?
Yeah,
and she's and she sat down.
She sat down next to me afterwards.
I was watching the late game and she's like,
is this game going to make you upset?
Oh my God.
The amount of times,
Nia,
I swear to God that if you were a guy,
I would just start swinging.
That was one of those moments I want to start swinging.
Wouldn't I would have done the most,
well,
most guys do acted like I was going to swing and not well,
you want to do
bring it.
I'm not the one.
You know what?
I am the one,
you can talk all this shit.
You want to,
I'm an old man.
Let's go bro.
You want to do this bro?
Frat white guys when they're like talking top of the bar.
Let's go bro.
Yeah.
You know what fucking frat boy white guys also do.
They'll bite your ear off fucking lunatics.
Especially if their dad's a judge.
Um,
you had to do it depends on like what fucking,
yeah.
Yeah.
I stayed out of that world.
I did not like that world at all.
That world was fucked right when,
when I came,
the shit that they used to do to people during fucking hazing,
the fucking stories.
I'm telling you the stories that fucking guys got from getting hazed too.
It was,
it was fucking,
what is the deal with like the like Frat Guy?
Like white Frat guys.
I mean,
a lot of guys can drink a lot,
but like they,
they really make it like a competitive thing.
I'm not talking about that.
And it'd be a,
we stuck a fucking character up.
Pazazz kid was screaming.
I just don't,
I remember that was one of my first jokes in my stand up back.
Yeah.
People go,
how come you didn't join a Frat?
I was like,
I dunno,
cause it Kinda got this thing about letting other guys show fruit up my ass.
And I used to get a laugh back in the 90s because everybody knew,
oh that was like funny.
Like oh hazing.
And now it's like people actually die from that.
So No,
you don't die from that.
You did souls crushed.
How about talking about them making you drink all the water and all that?
You know when he eat all these pancakes and then they die,
that's millennial shit.
I'm talking about what the fuck they used to decent fucking beat the shit out of
you and fucking a ass rapey with fucking it nuts.
The stories.
I used to hear
the shit I used to fucking hear that people used to do to each other and I,
and I was just like,
I used to always think of that and then what?
Then you get to hang out with them afterwards.
I'm not seeing that always fucking happened.
But Dude,
some of this shit,
this at one ivy league school with it.
This is some pew pancake you have to fucking eat.
And somebody finally said something about it and all these older people,
I think it was a Dartmouth or something and they were all mad like dude acute
believe it's called.
It's called no,
it's called the vomit.
That's so disgusting.
Why?
Why,
why is that necessary?
It's a to be in a,
in a group to do that sort of thing because they're fucking losers.
Like cause cause cause your,
cause you're exploiting somebody at a very weak moment in their life.
They've left their parents,
they,
they need new friends.
They want to feel like I always was just yeah I draw.
Yes.
Hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
You should hear the fucking stories.
Like some of my relatives were in frats,
some of the shit they did to them took them outside the dead of winter,
sprayed him with like a fire hose because somebody threw a bucket of paint on
one of the older brothers or whatever.
Spreading with bucket pate.
Yeah.
It's got like fucking pneumonia almost died.
They could just beat the shit out of here.
It was bad.
Then every once in a while you heard the fruit that I want to make it seem like
everybody did that.
I remember being a gold's gym and this guy was sitting,
I think it was just talking about Hasan,
people at football camp and he was going like,
yeah.
Then we shoved it carried a possessed kid was fucking,
and they're hazing experience but like anonymously cause you know,
I don't want to do that.
I'm not,
am I going to do a fucking me to guy thing here?
All right.
I don't want to blame the victims,
but I heard what happened and I was just like,
yeah,
fuck frats.
I'll get my own friends.
Yeah,
you gonna you gonna you gonna rush a Frat.
I'll think about it buddy.
Are you,
would you just,
you do not have the personality to be in a fraternity at all.
Yeah.
That is the opposite that you would,
you would,
you,
you wouldn't even get past the first day.
Yeah.
I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't get through the fucking army.
I can get to the army.
You couldn't hear you.
Yeah,
you did.
What are you going to do?
Beat the shit out of me then.
I don't have to go to war.
I'll do that.
Oh,
did I get a dishonorable discharge?
I'm still,
I'm still fucking here.
I'll do that.
Right.
Private bearskin whole Sassy.
No,
I never would have made no,
here's the deal.
At my age outlet when I was young kid,
I would have done whatever the fuck they said.
If I was 18,
19,
I would have done whatever the fuck they said.
Yeah.
So that's why they do it.
But yeah.
Anybody middle-aged.
Alright,
good.
And do it.
Yeah.
I'd be like Michael J.
Fox and like,
yeah.
What are,
what are we doing here?
[inaudible] all right.
That's it.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I need to worry him on this podcast.
Uh,
I'll talk to you guys on Thursday,
right?
If you want to throw in your fucking hate your football hazing in,
in,
um,
yeah,
I'm above all of that shit.
I remember like faculty members going talking about Shit that they saw fucking
older kids doing.
The other kids.
Yeah.
Women too.
I want to hear like the Sorority,
and I don't want to hear it because it's at this fucking time,
because what you're going to do is they're creating,
this is how they,
everybody's looking at like Hollywood right now.
Like it's this giant non-consent consensual,
like fucking a orgy.
And it isn't.
Most people are here busting their ass to fucking great people and all that,
but then now they're going to say that everybody's out here of,
you know,
fucking soccer.
Derek,
you're not going to get a fucking commercial.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
there's so many amazing,
wonderful people that work in the industry.
So that's true.
That's very true.
And if they all have to go down,
I don't give a fuck because I'm a white chicken.
My twenties all right,
go fuck yourselves up to check in on you on Thursday.